Ryan Reynolds a lot is riding on this
movie buddy a lot safe house stars
Denzel Washington and Ryan Reynolds and
as I said my opening this is a movie
that is very big for Ryan Reynolds
because he really didn't have the best
2011 last year was not a good year for
him for movies safe house is about this
guy Ryan Reynolds he's a housekeeper of
this safe house it's a place where they
can house criminals who are being
transported somewhere something and he
runs into Denzel Washington Denzel
Washington in this movie is one of the
most feared criminals in the entire
world and Ryan Reynolds is just the guy
who answers the phones all day in this
place alone without any help and there's
this huge like ambush that happens and
Ryan Reynolds is the only person left
alive he's then forced to be like the
one guy who protects Denzel Washington
and transports into some sort of prison
because dens I was carrying this very
sensitive piece of information that
we're not really sure what it's about
Ryan Reynolds tends to overact a little
bit in the emotional scenes he gets
really like like really in the heat of
the moment and everything sometimes that
works in movies but sometimes when you
watch an actor just like
hyperventilating it's okay they wouldn't
really do that in real life but I'm
going to give him credit because I think
for the most part he was really good in
this movie Denzel Washington is Denzel
Washington you're not gonna go to a
movie and watch a two-time Academy Award
winner stink up the place Denzel
Washington is a class act
he is always good in movies and he is
very good here and there's like this
great shot in the movie where he's just
like walking and he sees this one guy
who's after I mean he just we just like
keeps walking his character is very
entertaining I like that is all a lot in
this movie this is an OK film it's not a
great movie it's very much a retread of
things we've seen before the filmmaking
style is incredibly reminiscent of the
Bourne movies it cuts from intense CIA
discussions and computer operating rooms
to the action the movies directed in a
very shaky camp style but not
incomprehensible you can tell what's
going on to stop the director this
movie's Toby's a style that has worked
for the Bourne films and films like
taken but here just felt like the same
old news and it just seemed like a just
a copy of something we've seen before
there's a surprising amount of well
choreographed action good fight scenes
good car chases it's an entertaining
movie but the fact is it seems like they
were trying to mask poor storytelling
with
action like as soon as the scene we get
to a point where you feel like there are
unanswerable questions like a gun would
go off or something or a car would crash
and you have to okay we're an action
scene now we've seen your store like
this before it's acting with charisma by
these two leads it seems like it's
directed by a director who hasn't really
found his own style yet is trying to
emulate previous successes but to be
honest I didn't mind watching this movie
I enjoyed myself for the most part it's
not a terrible film it's not a great
film it's it's a good rental I don't
really think it's necessary to see in
theaters it's kind of in the middle for
me but I'm gonna give it a b-minus I was
fighting between a C+ and a b-minus but
the fact of the matter is I enjoyed
watching the movie for the most part so
b-minus for safe house I'd like to know
what is your favorite Denzel Washington
movie the guy has made a lot of great
films and he is awesome he's Denzel
Washington the man if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck my 9